my job was to stand behind the register
my dad's store my whole teenage years it
was slow like we didn't have that many
customers so I was able to watch people
and that's what I did I wasn't bored
there was no phones back there I would
read the wine spectator and then it says
ding this is the door opened I would
[ __ ] watch remember when I was
finally 22 and came from college and it
was my turn to run the business the
first thing I did I redid the whole
store basically my dad store was called
Shoppers Discount Liquors but I wanted
to be Wine Library and then what I did
was the right side that you never would
go towards I basically stopped
merchandising there because you weren't
going to see it anyway I made this
something called the top ten it just
said top ten but because it was
merchandisers one two three the number
one wine sold like it had no context and
then at the register I made it all
premium half bottles of champagne and
wine so instead of people grabbing like
nine Cent peanuts at the register they
were grabbing like seven dollar half
bottles of wine and then that skill set
got me to day one on winelibrary.com to
care about Shopper cart Dynamics day one